OPENING MONOLOGUE FOR THE
NEW YEAR
♪
>> Sean: DESPITE VICIOUS
MEDIA ATTACK AND MANY
POLITICAL OBSTACLES, 2017
WAS A VERY SUCCESSFUL FIRST
YEAR FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE ECONOMY.
THE DOW JONES WAS UP 25%
CREATED.
UNEMPLOYMENT.
YES, UNEMPLOYMENT AT 17-YEAR
LOW SINCE 4.1%.
SINCE TAKING OFFICE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS CREATED
1.7 MILLION NEW JOBS.
AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT 17-YEAR LOW.
WE ENDED THE YEAR WITH
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE SITTING
AT A 17-YEAR HIGH.
HOME PRICES ARE UP 6% AS IS
HOME BUILDING.
REGULATIONS HAVE BEEN
SLASHED AT HISTORIC RATE.
AND THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
CUT 16 REGULATIONS FOR EVERY
NEW ONE THAT WAS CREATED.
ALSO, LET'S TALK ABOUT
G.D.P.
NOW, SO FAR UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP, WE HAVE SEEN TWO
QUARTERS OVER 3%.
LET'S COMPARE THAT WITH
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
THE ONLY PRESIDENT IN THE
FOR AN ENTIRE YEAR.
AND WE CAN'T FORGET ABOUT
STAMPS AND IN POVERTY.
95 MILLION AMERICANS OUT OF
THE LABOR FORCE.
THE WORST ECONOMIC RECOVERY
SINCE THE 1940S, THE LOWEST
LABOR PARTICIPATION RATE
SINCE THE 1970S, THE LIST
GOES ON.
WORST RECOVERY SINCE THE
1940S, WORST HOME OWNERSHIP
RATE IN 51 YEARS.
UNLIKE OBAMA, BUSINESS
CONFIDENCE IS NOW SOARING
UNDER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE NEWS IS SO GOOD THAT
THIS.
HEADLINE.
I DIDN'T MAKE IT UP.
THE TRUMP EFFECT.
BUSINESS ANTICIPATING LESS
REGULATION.
LOOSENS THE PURSE STRINGS.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE HAVE
COUPLE THAT WITH THE BRAND
NEW 1.5 TRILLION-DOLLAR TAX
PLAN.
THAT IS NOW TAKING EFFECT OF
WHAT YOU HAVE A RECIPE FOR A
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
YOU ARE BEGINNING TO SEE THE
DIRECT IMPACT OF THIS TAX
BILL.
FOR EXAMPLE, COMPANIES LIKE
BOEING, AT&T, COMCAST, WELLS
ALL ANNOUNCED EMPLOYEE
BONUSES OR PAY INCREASES
FOLLOWING THAT BILL U THAT'S
REAL MONEY BACK IN THE
POCKETS OF THE FORGOTTEN MEN
AND WOMEN THAT DESERVE IT IN
THIS COUNTRY.
TAKE A LOOK, FOR EXAMPLE,
WHAT HAPPENED OVER AT, YEAH,
LIBERAL CBS NEWS.
HOW THE TAX PLAN IS GOING TO
IMPACT THE MIDDLE CLASS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
UH-OH DIDN'T COME OUT THE
WAY THEY EXPECTED.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE WANT TO SEE HOW FOLKS
WOULD ACTUALLY FARE.
ASKED HOUSEHOLDS FROM THREE
DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY TO SEND US THEIR TAX
RETURNS AND HAD AN
ACCOUNTANT CALCULATE HOW
THINGS WILL CHANGE FOR EACH
OF THEM.
CAROLINA, HER INCOME LAST
$40,000.
>> I GOT GOOD NEWS FOR YOU,
MARCY, YOU ARE GETTING MORE
MONEY BACK NEXT YEAR.
>> AMBER AND JASON EDWARDS
WERE ALSO HOPING FOR GOOD
PRESSURE ON THE MIDDLE
CLASS, WHETHER IT DOES OR
NOT, I DON'T KNOW.
>> I ACTUALLY THINK THEY
WOULD PAY TAX ON ABOUT
$12,000 MORE OF INCOME BUT
BECAUSE OF THE LOWER RATES,
THEY ACTUALLY END UP SAVING
A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY.
>> HONESTLY, I'M A LITTLE
SURPRISED BECAUSE WHAT YOU
HAD SAID INITIALLY YOU
THOUGHT WE WERE GOING TO
>> THEY'RE NOT THE ONLY
ONES.
MELISSA AND LANE ALSO
EXPRESS CONCERN ABOUT NEXT
YEAR'S TAXES.
>> I'M THINKING THEY ARE
GOING TO BE HIGHER.
>> OVERALL, HE ESTIMATES
THEY WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
NEARLY $13,000 LESS IN
TAXES.
>> WELL, THAT'S GOOD.
>> I LIKE OUT SOUND OF THAT.
>> CAN I GET THE ACCOUNT AT
THAT PARTICULAR
ATAT PARTICULAR
ATTH PARTICULAR
ATTHATARTICULAR
ATTHAT PTICULAR
ATTHAT PARCULAR
ATTHAT PARTILAR
ATTHAT PARTICUR
ATTHAT PARTICULAR
ACTHAT PARTICULAR
ACCOAT PARTICULAR
ACCOUN PARTICULAR
ACCOUNTAARTICULAR
ACCOUNTANTTICULAR
ACCOUNTANT'SCULAR
ACCOUNTANT'S NLAR
ACCOUNTANT'S NUMR
ACCOUNTANT'S NUMBER AFTER.
GOING TO SEE A DECREASE IN
THEIR TAXES.
>> EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THOSE
FAMILIES WILL HAVE MORE
MONEY IN THEIR POCKET NEXT
FAMILIES ARE SAVING MONEY.
THE TAX CUT WILL HELP MIDDLE
CLASS FAMILIES.
THEY DESPERATELY NEED IT.
AND BY THE WAY THE BILL ALSO
GETS RID OF THE OBAMACARE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATED AND IT
OPENS UP ENERGY EXPLORATION
IN ANWR.
OH YOU, THE LIFE BLOOD OF
OUR ECONOMY, MORE ENERGY
JOBS AT HIGH WAGES FOR
AMERICANS.
AND LOWER PRICES FOR THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
ALL GOOD.
UNLEASHED THE U.S. MILITARY
AND AS A RESULT, LETTING
THEM DECIDE ALL BUT DESTROY
THE TERROR GROUP.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED OUT.
THE MILITARY UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S LEADERSHIP HAS DONE
HIS LAST 28 MONTHS.
AND THAT'S JUST A SMALL
2017.
TAKE A LOOK ON YOUR SCREEN
RIGHT THERE.
HERE IS A LIST OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S ACCOMPLISHMENTS FOR
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, THE
DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA, ANYBODY
ON THE LEFT.
ANY LIBERAL EVER MENTION ANY
OF THESE THINGS?
HAVE YOU HEARD THEM TALK
ACCOMPLISHMENTS HAVE
POSITIVELY IMPACTED THE
COUNTRY?
PROBABLY NOT.
THEY WANT AND HAVE WANTED
FROM THE BEGINNING THE
PRESIDENT TO FAIL U NOW,
THIS IS EXACTLY WHY THE
MEDIA, THE PUNDITS, THE
POLITICAL ELITES ARE
PREDICTING A HUGE MASSIVE
DEMOCRATIC LANDSLIDE IN
NOVEMBER OF THIS YEAR IN THE
MID TERMS.
BUT, BEFORE THEY GET TOO
GIDDY, TOO EXCITED, LET'S
KEEP THIS IN MIND.
THESE ARE THE SO-CALLED SAME
EXPERTS, POLITICAL EXPERTS
WHO ALL SAID PRESIDENT TRUMP
NEVER STOOD A CHANCE.
THE BRAKES HERE AND NOT GET
SO GIDDY.
HAS CREATED WHAT I AM
CALLING FOR A BLUEPRINT FOR
VICTORY IN 2018.
I HOPE THE REPUBLICANS IN
WASHINGTON ARE PAYING
ATTENTION.
NOW THEY DID GET THEIR ACT
TOGETHER IN DECEMBER.
I DO GIVE THEM CREDIT.
BUT THEY NEED TO DO MORE
THEY NEED TO KEEP THE
MOMENTUM GOING.
TAX CUTS THAT'S A GREAT
START.
THEY NEED TO KEEP BUILDING
THE WALL.
FINISH REPEALING OBAMACARE
WHICH IS A DISASTER.
REPLACE IT WITH FREE MARKET
SOLUTIONS.
PASS WELFARE REFORM IT'S
DESPERATELY NEEDED AGAIN.
CUT OTHER WASTEFUL
GOVERNMENT SPENDING
PROGRAMS.
WE KNOW THE DEMOCRATS ARE
THESE UPCOMING NEGOTIATIONS
IN COMING WEEKS.
REPUBLICANS, YOU NEED TO
SHOW SOME BACKBONE, AT LEAST
FOR ONCE.
STAND UP FOR PRINCIPLES.
YOU ALWAYS GET THE TAX CUT.
YOU NEVER GET THE TAX CUT.
YOU ALWAYS GET THE TAX HIKE.
YOU NEVER GET THE FUTURE
SPENDING CUTS.
WE ALWAYS GET THE IMMEDIATE
CONCESSION OR AMNESTY.
BUT YOU NEVER GET THE BORDER
WALL BUILT.
YOU NEVER GET THE BORDER
SECURITY.
SO YOU REPUBLICANS, YOU NEED
TO TAKE THIS PAST APPROACH
AND FLIP IT UPSIDE DOWN
BECAUSE SO FAR IT FAILS
EVERY TIME.
SO THE G.O.P., YOU WANT TO
WIN IN NOVEMBER?
YOU NEED TO DEMAND THAT
THINGS LIKE THE BORDER WALL
WILL GET BUILT AND BUILT
FIRST.
BEFORE ANYTHING ELSE CAN
HAPPEN.
AS IT RELATES TO
IMMIGRATION.
NOW, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
THEY NEED TO SEE, 200,
300 MILES OF THIS BORDER
WALL BUILT BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
THAT WILL HELP YOU
POLITICALLY AND IT'S GOOD
ISSUES.
THAT'S THE BLUEPRINT
POLITICALLY FOR SUCCESS IN
2018 IN THE MID TERMS.
AND REPUBLICANS, YOU FOLLOW
THAT YOU WILL BE SUCCESSFUL.
ALSO TONIGHT, IF 2017 IS
DEFINED BY ANY ONE THING, IT
WILL BE THE NEWS MEDIA'S
EPIC FAIL.
WHAT DO D. WE HEAR ALL LAST
YEAR THE ENTIRE YEAR FROM
THE MAINSTREAM LIBERAL
COLLUSION, RUSSIA, RUSSIA.
THAT FAKE NEWS NARRATIVE HAS
COMPLETELY MUCH BLOWN UP IF
THEIR FACES AFTER A YEAR OF
NONSTOP BREATHLESS REPORTING
ANONE NEWS SOURCES, HYSTERIA
ON THEIR PART.
BECAUSE SO FAVOR, UP TO
TODAY, ZERO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION BETWEEN PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND THE RUSSIANS.
SO NOW THE MEDIA, THEY HAVE
GOT TO LATCH ON TO SOMETHING
QUICK.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
ADMITTED THEY ARE WRONG.
SO THE NEW NARRATIVE OF THE
LIBERAL MEDIA IS THAT
CONSERVATIVES ACTUALLY HATE
THE FBI.
WE'RE EXPOSING IN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
WATCH THIS.
IS SOME KIND OF-LIBERAL DEEP
STATE HORROR SHOW.
>> THE MESSAGE IS DON'T LOOK
AT OR THINK ABOUT WHAT MAY
BE UNDER INVESTIGATION.
LET'S FIND WHATEVER WE CAN
TO UNDERMINE THE PILLARS OF
THE RESPECT THAT WE TEND TO
CONFER UPON INSTITUTIONS
LIKE THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
>> THERE IS ONLY ONE
INSTITUTION THAT REALLY HAS
BEEN TAINTED THROUGH THESE
MONTHS.
AND THAT IS THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
IT'S TAINTED BY THE
PRESIDENT'S LIES, BY HIS
DISRESPECT FOR AMERICAN
INSTITUTIONS.
AT THE FBI AND IN THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY ARE
WORKING AS HARD AS EVER.
BUT THIS CAN'T BE GOOD FOR
MORALE.
>> Sean: THAT'S THE NEW
NARRATIVE.
CONSERVATIVES THIS IS
LAUGHABLE.
REPUBLICANS HATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND YOU KNOW WHY IT'S
NOT THE PEOPLE THAT RESPECT
LAW AND LAW
BEEN THAT WAY FOR DECADES.
WE WILL EXPLAIN IN A SECOND.
I WANT TO EDUCATE ALL MY
FAILING COLLEAGUES IN THE
MEDIA THAT HAVE BEEN WRONG
SO OFTEN.
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC, YOU
MIGHT INVESTIGATE HILLARY
CLINTON AND, YEAH, THE
NUMEROUS FELONIES WE KNOW
SHE COMMITTED.
IF YOU CARE ABOUT IT.
YOU SHOULD MAYBE LOOK INTO
HER TOP AIDE HUMA ABEDIN AND
CRIMINALLY MISHANDLING OF
CLASSIFIED INFORMATIONS THIS
REALLY CARED ABOUT TRUTH AT
ALL, MAYBE LOOK INTO THIS.
AND THAT'S MUELLER'S MERRY
BAND OF DEMOCRATIC DONORS
LET'S SEE, CONTRIBUTED, OH,
ONLY TO DEMOCRATS.
INVESTIGATING THROUGH A
SPECIAL COUNSEL HILLARY
CLINTON, YEAH, YOU GUYS NUT
MEDIA, YOU WOULD BE FOAMING
AT THE MOUTH ON A NIGHTLY
BASIS.
AND IF THE MEDIA, IF YOU ARE
INTERESTED IN TRUTH.
WHY DON'T YOU ASK WHY
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION WHY
DON'T THEY EVER DO SOMETHING
REALLY STUPID AND GIVE 20%
OF AMERICA'S URANIUM SUPPLY
TO RUSSIA?
YEAH.
THAT RUSSIA, PUTIN'S RUSSIA.
THE ADVERSARY.
THE BAD ACTOR RUSSIA.
WHEN BY THE WAY WE DON'T
EVEN HAVE ENOUGH URANIUM AS
IT IS.
AND MAYBE YOU FOLLOW THE
MONEY IF IT WAS DONALD TRUMP
AND $145 MILLION POURING
INTO THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
AND HER COVERS WHILE WHILE
SHE IS SECRETARY OF STATE
FROM THE VERY PEOPLE
INVOLVED IN THIS PARTICULAR
TRUMP, I KNOW YOU WOULD BE
OF COURSE YOU DON'T WANT TO
KNOW THAT TRUTH.
LET'S GO BACK TO THIS NEW
NARRATIVE COMING FROM THE
FAKE NEWS MEDIA THAT
CONSERVATIVES HATE OUT FBI.
THE EXACT OPPOSITE IS TRUE.
NOW, ON THIS SHOW, IF YOU
I HAVE ALWAYS RESPECTED THE
MEN AND WOMEN IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
POLICEMEN, FIREMEN,
OF COURSE, THE FBI.
THEY DO.
NOW THE BIASED PRESS, THEY
ARE THE ONES WHO HAVE THIS
HISTORY OF UTTER DISDAIN FOR
MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT,
FOR EXAMPLE, IT WASN'T THAT
LONG AGO THAT THE MEDIA WAS
TRASHING POLICE.
REMEMBER HOW MANY OF THEM
SUPPORTED BLACK LIVES
MATTER.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS.
THIS IS A GREAT INVENTION.
IT'S CALLED VIDEOTAPE.
REMIND YOU.
>> THOUSANDS OF AMERICANS
ARE MARCHING IN NEW YORK AND
WASHINGTON AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY DEMANDING A JUSTICE
SYSTEM THAT APPLIES THE SAME
TO EVERYBODY AND HONORS OUR
VALUES WE WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT OUR HEARTS ARE OUT
THERE MARCHING WITH THEM.
>> MANY AFRICAN-AMERICAN
PEOPLE SAID LOOK WE WERE
INTRODUCED TO TERROR LONG
BEFORE 9/11, THE VICIOUS
POLICE FORCES OF AMERICANS
THAT HAVE VICTIMIZED US AND
THE WAY WHITE SUPREMACY
BALTIMORE HAS HEIGHTENED
AWARENESS ONCE AGAIN OF
THE UTMOST RESPECT WE PRAISE
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE FBI,
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY.
THE ISSUE WE HAVE IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE IS VERY
SHOWN A VERY ANTI-TRUMP
POLITICAL BIAS.
SO, WE HAVE TO ASK THE MEDIA
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
DO YOU SUPPORT PEOPLE LIKE
PETER STRZOK, THE GUY THAT
HATES TRUMP, LOVES HILLARY,
THE FBI AGENT INVOLVED IN
EVERYTHING AND HIS FBI
LAWYER GIRLFRIEND LISA PAGE
TOGETHER BY THE WAY THEY
CALLED PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST
ABOUT EVERY SINGLE SWEAR
WORDS THAT I CAN EVEN THINK
OF AND I SWEAR.
AND BY THE WAY ATTACK TRUMP
AND THEIR SUPPORTERS.
THEY ALSO TEXTED ABOUT AN
INSURANCE POLICY IN ANDY'S
OFFICE WHICH WE THINK, OF
COURSE, IS DEPUTY FBI
DIRECTOR ANDREW MCCABE IN
CASE DONALD TRUMP ACTUALLY
PULLED OFF THE IMPOSSIBLE
AND WON THE ELECTION.
SO YOU MEDIA PEOPLE, DO YOU
SUPPORT PEOPLE LIKE THE
DISGRACE YOU HAD FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR COMEY ADMITTED
UNDER OATH TO HAVING HIS
FRIEND LEAK INFORMATION TO
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" IN THE
HOPING IT WOULD BRING ABOUT
A SPECIAL COUNSEL WHICH IT
THE LAW WRITING HIS TRUMP
NOTES ON FBI COMPUTERS AND
FROM THE BUREAU AND BY THE
WAY, EXONERATED HILLARY
CLINTON?
THIS IS MY FAVORITE.
IN THE EMAIL INVESTIGATION,
BEFORE HE EVER DID THE
INVESTIGATION.
I'M SURE IF THAT WAS AGAINST
AND THEN, OF COURSE,
MUELLER'S TEAM OF LIBERAL
DONATIONS.
AS WE HAVE TOLD YOU, OVER
$50,000 HIS TEAM HAS DONATED
OVER THE YIRSZ TO DEMOCRATS
AND NONE TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ONE OF MUELLER'S TOP
INVESTIGATORS JEANNE RHEE
INVESTIGATED THE
ADMINISTRATION DURING
RACKETEERING.
I GUESS THERE IS NO BIAS.
AGAINST ARTHUR ANDERSON AND
DESTROYED THE COMPANY COST
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
IN 2005 THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT TURNED OVER
WEISSMANN'S CONVICTION A 9-0
UNANIMOUS RULING.
WEISSMANN ALSO SENT FOUR
ALSO OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH
U.S. CIRCUIT COURT OF
APPEALS.
THAT'S MUELLER'S TEAM?
HIS WIFE NELLIE.
BRUCE OHR MET WITH FUSION
GPS.
YOU KNOW, THOSE OFFICIALS
THAT CAME UP PUT PHONY
RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA DOSSIER
THAT WE NOW KNOW HIS OWN
WIFE WAS WORKING ON THE
OPPOSITION AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP THAT PRODUCED AND
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR THAT
FAKE NEWS RUSSIA PROPAGANDA.
SOUNDS LIKE COLLUSION TO ME.
AND FINALLY, OF COURSE, THE
DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR ANDREW
MCCABE, HIS WIFE, JILL TOOK
OVER HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
FROM CLINTON ALLY FORMER
GOVERNOR TERRY MCAULIFF AND
DEMOCRATS FOR A FAILED
VIRGINIA STATE SENATE SEAT.
THAT'S AN INSANE AMOUNT OF
MONEY.
MCCABE IS ALSO DIRECTLY TIED
LIKE SO MANY OTHERS TOUT
DOSSIER.
AND DURING HER RECENT
TESTIMONY ON CAPITOL HILL
MCCABE CONFLICTED STATEMENTS
FROM PREVIOUS WITNESSES AND
ALSO CLAIMED NOT TO KNOW
WHEN HE FOUND OUT THE
CLINTONS AND THE DNC FUNDED
THE DOSSIER.
AND, ACCORDING TO REPORTS
MCCABE IS EXPECTED TO RETIRE
NEXT YEAR WITH A BIG FAT
TAXPAYER PENSION.
DOES ANY OF THIS MATTER TO
YOU IN THE LIBERAL
MAINSTREAM MEDIA OR DO YOU
JUST LIKE TO FAIL AND BE
ALL THESE PEOPLE?
YOU ARE SUPPORTS THAT
CONDUCT?
YOU ARE SUPPORTING THAT
POLITICAL BIAS?
YOU DON'T SEE A CONFLICT OF
THIS ISN'T CORRUPTION AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL?
YOU KNOW, THESE CRIMPLES
THAT WE
CRAT WE
CRIT WE
CRITICE
CRITICISMS WE ARE MAKING ARE
FACTS.
THEY ARE NOT ABOUT
INSTITUTIONS.
THEY ARE ABOUT THE VIOLATION
OF CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND
THE ABUSE OF POWER AT THE
TOUCH LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS SERIOUS.
AND WE HAVE BEEN RIGHT.
YOU HAVE BEEN WRONG.
FINALLY TONIGHT, THREE MAJOR
JONG UN IS THREATENING THE
UNITED STATES BY SAYING THAT
A NUCLEAR BUTTON IS ALWAYS
ON HIS DESK AND THAT HE HAS
NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAT CAN NOW
REACH THE UNITED STATES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST ABOUT
WELL 45 MINUTES AGO FIRED
BACK ON TWITTER SAYING WELL,
HE HAS AN EVEN BIGGER
NUCLEAR BUTTON AND HIS
ACTUALLY WORKS.
WE HAVE MORE ON THAT LATER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS ACTUALLY
PUTTING PAKISTAN ON NOTICE
BY TWEETING AND CALLING THEM
OUT FOR HELPING TERRORISTS
STORY, PROTESTS CONTINUING
TONIGHT TO BREAK OUT IN
KILLED.
OVER 450 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED.
NOW, THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT
REPREIVE
REPRESVE
REPRESSIVE ARE
REPRESSIVE RRE
REPRESSIVE REGIME AND
RADICAL MULLAHS IN IRAN.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP PREDICTED
KILLED FOR BEING GAY AND